I refused as a 41 year old woman in 2016
to experience any amount of body shaming
that's Law & Order SVU star Stephanie
March opening up about the essay she
wrote for refinery29
about her horrifying experience getting
breast implants in 2014 which led to
several hospitalizations and intensive
treatments you can't make me feel
ashamed for something that I'm not
afraid to talk about and I can't
possibly be alone and I'm not
embarrassed Stephanie got candid with
ETS Jennifer perros on Wednesday at her
makeup store Rouge New York today she
says she has a new outlook on life and
is more grateful than ever for her good
health it is a gift to be able to get up
every day and walk a mile in the city
and get a cup of coffee and and move
about and do what I want to do I owe my
good health to appreciating that did it
teach you a lesson taught me a lot of
lessons when you want to fix something
in your life look to your heart for more
with Stephanie March tune into et
Thursday July 7th
you